Let's talk a little bit ,about how to implement consistent
hashing. One option is for every node to know the
location of every other node. In this case, lookups are
fast. In fact, they are order one, but the routing
tables are large. In particular, because every node needs to
know the location of every other node in the network.
The routing table, must be order N, where n is
the number of nodes in the network. So ,for example,
if node 32 wanted to look up the location
of Annie Hall, that value might hash to 60,
and if every node maintains a routing table entry
for every other node, 32 would know that the key
corresponding to ID 60 was located at node one.
So the look up, would be order one, but the
table ,would be order N. Another option, is that
each node, only knows the location of its immediate successor
in the ring. So for example ,node 32, would
know the location of node 43, but of no
other node. This results in a small table, of
size order one. But locating the content, as before,
would require order N lookups. So in summary, if
every node knows the location of every other node,
then lookups have good performance at the expense of
larger tables. If every node only knows its successor ,then
routing tables can be small, but every lookup operation is order N.